I'm Steven Weinberg I guess in this
group I'm the dull guy because I'm a
theoretical physicist now I always
wanted to be a theoretical since at
least since high school
and I don't understand why other people
are theoretical I'm not be fraught about
my work I work in the theory of
elementary particles in quantum field
theory which is essentially the same
thing and I have the sideline working in
cosmology and I'm also extremely
interested in the history of physics and
trying to write something history from
Fairley's to Newton about the topics
that we discussed here there I have a
wide open mind about some of them of
reality and naturalism I really don't
know a useful definition of what they
mean I'm all for them with consciousness
and mathematics I think I know what they
are but I don't see how they fit into
natural science and that's also a
subject that I'm really open to
enlightenment we other than on some
other topics on the list emergence
morality and three well I have strong
views which I think are unlikely to
change snarling
you